-Our next guest is an
Emmy Award-winning actress
you know best from
her work on the
critically acclaimed series
"Killing Eve."
She stars in "Free Guy,"
which premieres in theaters
on August 13th.
Let's take a look.
-♪ It's such
a sweet, sweet fantasy, baby ♪
-You know,
people say it all the time,
like, "Guy can take [bleep]
in the face
better than anybody I know."
[ Laughs ]
I mean, when you put in that...
-♪ But it's just a
sweet, sweet fantasy, baby ♪
♪ When I close my eyes,
you come and take me ♪
♪ On and on and on ♪
-Don't have a good day.
Have a great day.
-I love that song.
[ Music stops ]
-That's a new one.
-Please welcome back
to the show Jodie Comer.
How are you, Jodie?
-Hey, Seth. I'm good.
How are you?
-I'm wonderful.
It's so nice to see you again.
This is a really fun movie.
Very different from what
we have come to see from you
in "Killing Eve."
What made you
want to do this project?
-Oh, my God.
Well, I think the first thing
was the opportunity
to work with Shawn Levy and
Ryan Reynolds, you know?
I knew that it was going to be
a tremendous amount of fun,
and to read the script,
you know,
it was a new kind of
fresh concept.
It had a lot of imagination.
And I didn't know how
they were going to execute it.
So it was such a joy
to be a part of.
-And really just
a face-altering wig, Jodie.
I mean, that's as unrecognizable
as I could think
that a wig would make you.
-It deserves
its own credit, Seth.
No, me and that wig --
we have come a long way.
I remember when
we started filming --
Before we started filming,
we had costume
and hair fittings, and there was
like five wigs in the running.
Four of them are great,
one I wasn't so keen on,
and I was just like,
"You know what, guys?
There's just no way.
We shouldn't photograph this.
We should just, you know,
send the other four."
And they were like, "No, no,
we should photograph it
and we should put it
with the four,
because there's just
no way they're going to
pick this when
they see the rest of them."
So I was like, "Okay, then."
[ Laughs ]
And then it was
like two days later,
and they all kind of came to me
in the makeup trailer
and just gave me a look.
And I was like, "They chose
the wig, didn't they?"
They were like, "Yeah."
So, yeah, we've come a long way.
-Yeah.
-We've come a long way.
-Jodie, you forgot the
first rule of show business --
never let them take a picture of
you in the wig you don't like.
-Seth, now I know.
This is the last time.
-Did you ever use it
for the purposes of anonymity?
I mean, you could walk around,
I feel like,
with that wig and get away with
being Jodie Comer.
-I haven't, unfortunately.
My friend -- Actually, my friend
who I spoke to you last time,
the Bruce Springsteen friend --
she came in to Boston
to visit and she had it on
in the trailer
while she was there, so I've got
a few novelty pictures of her.
She looks about 45,
which is brilliant.
Yeah.
-I think people would assume,
based on your work
as an assassin in "Killing Eve,"
that would be
the most stunts you would
do in a project,
but you actually had to do
a fair amount of
stunt work in this.
Maybe more intense?
-Yeah, I think so.
Like, I think people
tend to think "Killing Eve"
is very stunt-heavy,
but it isn't.
But, no, on this, like,
when I went to Boston,
it was like three hours a day
with the stunt department.
And I was so eager to do
as much as I possibly could.
Of course, I had
an incredible stunt double
called Hayley Wright.
But, yeah, I was
desperate to be cool.
-But you -- Did I hear correctly
that you got kicked
in the face, Jodie?
-I did.
I did get kicked in the face.
There was a -- There was an
accident in a stunt,
and I did get kicked
in the face.
And it was very sobering.
And -- But I also
do believe that everyone
should get kicked in their face
at least once in their life.
-Yeah, well,
you filmed in Boston,
so you're not the first person.
In Boston, that's a form of
affectionate greeting.
-Yeah. It's like, in Glasgow,
a head butt is called
a "Glasgow Kiss."
-Right.
-Yeah.
-That's called a "Fenway Hello."
-I would imagine
that, being from Liverpool,
that would be a place
that is very taken aback
when people try to do
a Liverpool accent
and get it wrong.
Boston, obviously,
is very similar.
Did you -- Would you even
attempt to do
a Boston accent
after spending time there?
-I've tried
and I failed miserably.
It's really, really hard to do.
And I actually think Bostonians
are quite precious,
like Scousers are
with the Liverpool accent.
Like, if someone doesn't do it
right, they really --
they really make sure
that you know
that you didn't do it right.
So I found a fair amount of
that in the --
-Yeah. They're not a coy people.
-They're not shy. No, no, no.
-No.
-But I love that. I love that.
-A famously opinionated stock,
the Bostonians.
And I want to ask, as well --
I know you are doing
a fourth season now --
are you excited about what we're
going to see with "Killing Eve"?
-Yes, I am.
We're halfway through Season 4.
I obviously can't say much,
but we've definitely got off
to an exciting start.
I think now that, because we
know that it's the final season,
they're definitely
kind of pushing boundaries,
especially with Villanelle.
You know, where we kind of
open up with her is
bonkers and kind of brilliant.
So, yeah, I hope people enjoy
when it finally hits the screen.
-I mean, is -- Are you --
You know, you mentioned
it is the final season.
You know, this was such a
transformative part for you,
personally.
Like, have you been
mourning the fact that
you are saying
goodbye to Villanelle?
-Not yet,
because I can't let myself.
I have like
two whole months left.
I had, like,
a little moment the other day
where I seen the clapper board
and I had, like, this
kind of lump in my throat
and I was like,
"Gosh, I've got a whole other
two months to go."
It's like a marathon.
Like, you can't think --
If you're at the start line,
you can't think of the finish.
Not that I've ever run
a marathon,
but that's what I imagine.
-No, I think you got it.
I think you got it.
And if you do ever
run a marathon,
we would like to request
you do it in that wig.
-[ Laughs ]
For you, I will.
-Thank you.
-I will.
-Hey, it's always
so lovely to see you, Jodie.
Congratulations on everything,
and hopefully, next time,
we will see you in person.
-Thanks so much, Seth.
-Alright, be well.
"Free Guy" is this theaters
this Friday.